Nearly half of Americans don't brush their teeth enough...
...and when food builds up in those nooks and crannies.
You're inviting a host of bacteria to the party,...
...including your gum line.
Which irritate and inflame your gums...
...causing tenderness and bleeding but that's just the start.
Soon enough that infection will trigger your immune system...
...which sends fighter cells to battle the bacteria.
This creates a hostile environment for the bacteria...
...which is what you want.
But it can also damage the cells in nearby tissue and bone.
Six months to years later, that tissue and bone will eventually die.
At this point, you don't have gingivitis anymore...
...you have something much worse:...
...Periodontal disease.